hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and by now in this society we
live in everyone understands that
information is something very important
whether it's the kind of information we
get over the Internet in terms of news
and what's happening what the weather is
going to be like the next day but also
information in a more technical sense if
you have a company needs information
about what sales are going on where the
customers are what products are
available and what you should be selling
if you're a scientist information is the
data that you have about the universe
information is another way of thinking
about what we know about the world so
it's an extremely general concept but
there is so much information around us
right now that it becomes a subject in
its own right to understand what
information is and how best to harness
it and there's really no better person
to talk to than today's guests azar
hidalgo say czar was trained as a
physicist but he quickly got into the
idea of statistical mechanics of
information which led him believe in rod
into economics and he started studying
not just economics in its own right but
how data flows through economic channels
and how it becomes actual physical
products so now after spending a long
time as the lead of mi t--'s collective
learning group say czar is newly a chair
at the university Toulouse in France but
he's also the head of a startup company
called data wheel
he's been very involved in data
visualization and how that can help us
understand what's happening in different
places around the world I can really
recommend his book called why
information grows that starts much like
this conversation you're about to listen
to does from the basics of what we mean
by information at the level of physics
or even philosophy into how information
moves around whether it's through a
biological organism through a society
through a culture through an economy
it's a different lens it's a different
way of thinking about what's going on
all around us and says ours a very
charismatic proponent of thinking about
information in interesting ways so I
think you're gonna like this let's go
[Music]
these are her dogs Oh welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you so you do
you started as a physicist is that right
that's right and you moved through at
any point we were officially an
economist no I never got a degree in
economics but I've been working on
topics related to economics I would say
now for 14 15 years okay so you know the
lingo you're pretty exactly and I have a
lot of colleagues and enemies in it but
now you're also very interested in data
visualization and things like that so to
people who are not an expert in any of
these areas what is the 30,000 foot view
of all this like how do you think of
your project of putting these things
together so the way that I define my
work is I say that I focus on collective
learning so what I try to do is to
understand how teams see these nations
and countries learn how do they acquire
new knowledge and how they put that new
knowledge to use and to do that I do a
lot of things I the creation diffusion
and valuation of knowledge and I've
contributed a lot to that literature and
economic geography and innovation but I
also have created lots of platforms to
integrate and distribute large volumes
of public and private data as a way to
improve the way that we see our world ok
and does the physics background help you
here I think so because at the end of
the day what you rescue from an
education like that of physics is that
to understand the world you need to
always have an interplay between
theories and experience you know so that
duality is useful in physics but is
useful in economics and is useful in
moral most other fields so I do think
that my work still it's always in the
boundary between what the data is
telling us and how interpret it ok but
even more than that you have so I read
your wonderful book why why information
grows yes and the word information is
obviously playing a large role here
right and information has different
definitions in different contexts it's
closely related things like entropy that
physicists care about so what how do you
think about information what is your
ideas and you say that word yeah and of
course it depends with whom I talking to
but in in a more technical sense I like
to think of information as like this
sort of like third thing that is very
basic and important to
so in the universe we have sort of
things you know that don't matter things
that we can you know we can touch or
that that have some sort of embodiment
you know but we also have the movement
of those things we can think of in terms
of energy and momentum and so forth but
there's a third you know quantity that
we need to consider which is not things
nor how they're moving but how they're
arranged or ordered and to me that's the
basic idea of information you know it's
like you know the sequence of things the
way in which you stack a deck of cards
if you shuffle a deck of cards you don't
change the mass you don't change the
energy but you're changing something
that order is information I guess
probably people when you say the word
information they think that information
is about something right that it
contains meaning not just not just data
so when you shuffle a deck of cards the
meaning doesn't really change or maybe
it does I'm not quite sure how you think
about it yeah so maybe a better analogy
than a deck of cards is to think of DNA
so if I change the sequence of you know
nucleic acids on DNA I can transform you
know one piece of DNA from encoding one
protein to encoding a different protein
like that protein and what it does and
you know in the context in which it's
being used you can think of that as the
meaning but the little piece of DNA that
is a certain sequence doesn't know
really about that meaning that meaning
is beyond it it's it's part of the
environment and the way that that
sequence of order interacts with the
rest of the environment so I tried to
think of information when I think about
it in fundamental terms as those
sequences but of course when I'm talking
with someone for example from the field
of communication or Media Studies
understand that information there is
much more related to meaning and you can
have concepts like misinformation which
in the DNA example you know would be a
little bit you know harder to build I
guess that's what that's what I'm trying
to get at so for the DNA molecule or
just for a set of letters on a page is
any arrangement equally containing the
same amount of information or do they
contain more information if the context
they're in cares about what they say in
some way well you know it depends on
which definition were using again so so
if we're thinking carnal from a pure
Shannon perspective you know basically a
random
sequence is gonna be the one that
contains more information person is the
hardest to predict you know you know it
means nothing
exactly but let's say now we're in the
context of communication you know and
I'm trying to communicate something to
you well the words that are gonna
contain more information are the ones
that reduce your uncertainty more about
what I'm trying to say you know so maybe
a more useful way to think about
information in that context is not
simply how many bits do I need to encode
something but how much do I reduce your
uncertainty with each bit that I provide
to you okay good this is sounding nice
and physics you know like this we're
gonna get to the role of information in
economies and firms and networks and
things like that but let's stick with
the physics angle here I mean how do you
think about the origin of information on
you all the way back to sort of the
evolution of the universe or the
evolution of life or something like that
that's a good question because in some
way information and order and complexity
is conspicuous in our planet so we were
marveled at it every time we go and see
a landscape or or you know like walk
around the city but at the same time you
know if we were to take a spaceship and
travel you know across our solar system
or or beyond we would see a universe
that is quite barren you know complexity
is not everywhere complexity actually
concentrates in places like like our
planet on and it leads us to ask why why
is our planet so rich in complexity
where other places you know are so
barren and like the moon is not exactly
the moon is not complex or even like if
you go to that accommodates are here in
our planet you're gonna find you know
places that actually you know don't have
too much structure beyond in the
geological formations that you can find
there and some telescopes these days by
the way yeah so to understand the origin
of of this complexity and disorder I
think the the best solutions that I
found there is work like that of air
pre-washing
you know so Ilya you know as you know
very well it's a very famous you know
statistical physicists and chemists you
know that he started to study physical
systems that we're out of equilibrium
you know near equilibrium but out of it
and and he found that those systems that
were out of equilibrium tended to
self-organize into what he called
dissipative structures
so think of the little whirlpool that
forms when you take the plunger out of a
bathtub no that's a structure that is
not haphazard you know there are
correlations there there's certain order
there structure you know and that is
structure is something that emerges you
know when that system is going through a
state in which it's flowing you know in
the system in which is like going from
one energy state to another so he says
when the systems are out of equilibrium
when they're moving from one state to
another there's kind of organize and
that is an important clue because if we
think about it a lot of the structure
that we have serve in nature you know
it's in life and life is an out of
equilibrium system that has to be
sustained by energy flows we have to eat
many times a day you know we're
breathing and you know we do get energy
also out of the oxygen that would be so
there's you know a lot of energy
consumption that we need to stay out of
equilibrium because the only way to
maintain our level of organization is to
stay out of that equilibrium so I think
prigogine is the one that gives us a
first good clue of why there's structure
in the universe yeah so in other words
from the perspective someone like me if
you just let the system go all by itself
it would go to a maximum entropy state
try to be boring equilibrium who would
you know the the bathtub would just
become flat right the water on top of it
but you're saying following prigogine
that in the right circumstances if you
feed it some energy in fact some energy
in a low entropy form then it that it
obtains this orderly configuration I
guess exactly and that's conspicuous not
only in biology now our lives live
around electronics that you know they
become useless the moment that the
battery runs out you know so they're
able to process information they're able
to you know show information on their
screens you know
encoded as pixels or whatever you using
as a display type of technology because
they're consuming energy so that energy
consumption no it's essential to kind of
like keep order because otherwise you
know entropy that's what it does so what
should we say that differentiates really
the Earth from the moon in this case I
mean we're at the same distance from the
Sun right
but I think here there's a lot of things
that have happened that allow us to
preserve information effectively you
know and there's also like a chemical
complexity that maybe might be missing
in places like the moon so on the one
hand we do have an atmosphere you know
that makes a big difference you know and
we do have you know oceans you know
which you know also make big difference
and those structures together with
others have been able to create path
dependencies you know for replicators
like you know DNA and RNA you know to
create order sustain it and reproduce it
so in some way the complexity that we've
served today is not the result of like
an instantaneous event or or a condition
that is present today on earth and not
present in the moon but also of a long
path dependent process in which this
complexity has grown over time because
we're able to generate more of it per
unit of time than we lose you know right
yeah I mean I guess if I haven't
actually thought about this so I'm gonna
say things that could be disastrously
wrong but probably Venus even though it
has an interesting-looking atmosphere
the surface of it from the few pictures
that we have doesn't look that different
from the moon right I mean it's kind of
like there are some rocks lying around
and nothing more organized than that and
probably there are conditions
specifically to earth related to the
existence of both solids and liquids and
things like that that allow for these
channels to open up and complexity to
develop is that the right way to think
of it I think so yeah and of course you
know if this is a tough question if we
would have a succinct answer would have
had you know like the the soundbite that
solves the problem of the origins of
life yeah yeah no but I do think that
even though we might not have that we do
have clues of some of the conditions you
know that that lead you know to the
creation of complex structures such as
life and one of those is the need you
know to have energy flows but the need
also of not losing them that quickly you
know and to be able to preserve the
structure and and here on planet Earth
we do that by you know having certain
solids and crystals that support that
structure for instance you know DNA is a
very stable molecule that is able to
preserve a lot of complexity and
information over you know long periods
of time and you know with the ability to
replicate
you know as to have the conditions that
we need not only to preserve information
but then to make it raw and it's not
even perfectly stable right I mean if
DNA we're absolutely stable never
changed wouldn't do the job you need
this kind this flexibility I guess
exactly you need to be able to explore
you know those spaces of configurations
so that you can actually then you know
growing complexity because complexity
requires diversity so there's some
simple version of information which is
just that you know when entropy is low
there's secret in some sense there's a
lot of information because you know a
lot about the system but but you're
making the point that it's this
complexity that gives us the ability to
really make use of that information is
that the right way to say yeah I do
think that complexity in many ways is
kind of like a better term you know
maybe because a little bit more loosely
defined for most people but I do think
that you know when you talk about the
planet Earth as a planet that has a lot
of information maybe people you know
think about like the medium the
libraries when you think about it as a
place that is very complex
maybe people get a better idea that
we're talking about like that that
complexity that is involved in
ecosystems on our society that is absent
from the moon and it's also absent from
libraries yeah yeah so there's this
interplay I wish I understood it better
maybe because no one does between
complexity and information right in some
sense you're making the point that
complexity makes use of information and
information makes complexity possible so
there I'm not sure they're the same
thing but they're at least symbiotic
yeah I do I do think that they're
related and are part of kind of like a
you know a set of symbiotic
relationships the other aspect that I do
think is important on that relationship
is what I call the capacity to compute
you know so if we go back to the DNA
analogy you can think of the DNA and you
can think up the cell and DNA by itself
is quite useless it cannot reproduce by
itself it requires all of this machinery
you know and the same is true for a lot
of information that we have is like a
recipe without a kitchen you know and
without a cook you know cannot transform
itself into a dish so we do have also
that ability to then grab a piece of
encoded information as a set of
instructions and transform it into
something that ability to transform
information into new information or to
reproduce it or to recombine it you know
is that computational capacity that will
serve in biology will serve in society
and that I think is the true mystery so
I call that like knowledge and my
separation between knowledge and
information is information is what is
encoded and knowledge is this ability to
make okay and you can make things by you
know making a car a car is information
you know it's an organized structure
just like DNA you know or you know you
can have knowledge when you are making a
new cell type you know as cells
differentiate you know and that
knowledge that ability to make is
ultimately what is hard to accumulate
both at the biological level and at the
social level and you said the word
before computer ability compute now
you're saying the ability to make those
the same thing like in in a last
language you know totally relaxed
exactly at 30,000 feet away from or more
you know yes I would say you know you
have this order structures and you have
the ability to make those order
structures you know that ability to make
we can call it the ability to compute
the ability to transform a string of
bits into another string of bits where
those bits are encoded on a magnetic
tape or on a piece of DNA you know from
this perspective it would be relevant of
course you know there are another
situations in which you want to make
those distinctions right and and
presumably there's also phase
transitions or at least transformations
along the way where the system becomes
better and better at accumulating and
using information yep yep so life would
be one multicellular life I'm thinking
of all these things I just had a podcast
a little while ago with Kate Jeffery who
is a neuroscientist and you know I had
given a talk saying how complexity can
evolve and she wanted to say yes but
also it goes away sometimes because
there are disastrous events and exactly
it's not at all guaranteed that it comes
and just grows monotonically yeah indeed
and I think that's true for you know
economy societies and ecosystems you
know like we've seen the collapse of
ecosystems we we might be risking you
know a big ecosystem collapse now with
climate change you know and we do see it
in social processes right like process
of social unrest you know their
countries and sometimes everybody thinks
that they're going fine and you know
things you know turn very quickly you
know like what is happening in Chile
this week what you know has happened in
many places in the past
ya know worldwide this is definitely
going on so that so let's make that
transition so you know let's let's
presume that in the last 15 minutes
everyone understands the origin of life
and how it takes in low entropy energy
at what point does life become economics
at what point do we talk about trading
information back and forth like that so
so what I try to communicate in why
information grows I don't know if I
succeed but what I tried to communicate
is at the end of the day you have these
systems that have a finite ability to
accumulate knowledge that accumulate
that capacity to make and the only way
that those systems can transcend that
limited capacity is by developing you
know collective phenomena or collective
systems that include multiple units so
you go from single cellular organisms to
multicellular organisms because you
could never achieve the level of
complexity of a multicellular organism
with a single celled organism but
multicellular organisms you know they
peek at the human let's say you know
flower as far as we know as far as we
know you know and humans are also
blimmin at capacity the older you get
the more that you realize that you know
very very very very little you know
about everything that could eventually
be known so humans transcend the
capacity by forming teams teams
transcend those capacities by forming
organizations organizations resent those
capacities by belonging to industries
you know and also by having cities and
you have this different like Russian
doll structure of organizations that
then grow all the way to our planet in
which we are able to accumulate more
complexity and more knowledge more of an
ability to make by always renormalizing
ourselves into you know groups of the
units that bumped into a ceiling so
division of labor in some sense is
exactly what's solvable division of
knowledge which I would say is different
than addition of labor because like I
can have a division of labor in which
we're all doing the same thing and we
have more of us doing the same thing you
know but the division of knowledge is
quite different because we're doing
different things and we're passing on
you know those inputs to each other as a
way to create things that would be
possible for each one of us to do so
when you're making an aircraft is not
that you have 100,000 people company in
which everybody
making an era by themselves you know
with a hammer and no and with some metal
you know it's everybody's doing
something different and that allows them
you know to create a few aircraft a year
you know that are the product now if
you're in a lower complexity let's say
activity like the production of t-shirts
in that case you might have more of a
division of labor and less of a division
of knowledge you might have you know
warehouse is full of seamstress that
they're all doing the same tasks doing
the same shirt and in that case you have
more of a division of labor you have
economies of scale but you don't have
that division of knowledge that you
would have served in a complex industry
like pharmaceuticals or aircraft
manufacturing I presumed it for a
complicated aircraft there's literally
nobody who has all the knowledge of
course yeah that's that's the whole
point and that's the idea that you know
basically you know you can think of the
complexity of an industry as the number
of what I call person bytes of knowledge
person bytes yeah like whitey yes
exactly
I've noticed that that you would need
you know to to be able to create a
product yeah ok
but but was that did we skip ahead when
I think of economics in general I mean I
think a trade and barter and you know
maybe currency and value and those can
proceed this sort of division of
knowledge or not I'm not sure they're so
in some way you know my way to enter
economics has been through a gap in the
literature you know that that was there
in which products were very much
considered like some sort of
epiphenomena that was not very
differentiated in the economics
literature so you know economics is a
field that comes more from tradition of
like bankers and merchants you know so
it's kind of more or like about trade
and interest rate prices you know and
money and and you know the cost of
employment and those things but know
whether you're producing ladders or
you're producing you know apples or
you're producing cars or you know you're
producing t-shirts you know are things
that are differentiated not you know too
much you know in the models and and and
the empirical work that was
traditionally in the literature and I
think I was lucky to enter the field at
a moment in which a more fine grained
data was becoming available
and that allowed us to start
characterizing products and industries
you know in a more fine-grain matter you
know not just by talking about how much
labor or capital they need but by
actually looking at you know the the
patterns of production to be able to
infer you know how much knowledge they
need to be produced you know or you know
other other properties that that
differentiate them in ways that the
traditional literature had not maybe
paid attention to so do you think that
kind of differentiation was there from
the start from the first primitive
economies or is it something that
allowed the economies to take off later
in the game and know that
differentiation is actually very hard to
achieve so one thing that is quite
conspicuous when you look at
international trade data or you look at
data on the geography of industrial
economic or innovative activities you
know in a country is that as you move
from the simple economic units the
town's to the more complex the cities or
you move from countries that you know
are relatively down in the development
ladder to the ones that are at the top
you have like this subset structure in
which diversity grows you know with the
level of development and complexity so
that the places that do few things they
not only do few things they do things
that are common to the places that do
many things you know so you have kind of
like this world in which creating that
diversity is difficult and those that
don't have it are stacked not only with
a primitive and limited offer but one
that is very redundant with everyone
else so it's very uncompetitive to so
these are also mechanisms that would
actually help us explain you know part
of the inequality because you know if
what I can do is something that
everybody can do and it's a few set of
things it's very hard for me to be
competitive and have a decent income if
I can do a lot of things that nobody
else can do and people want I think I
haven't made I want to pause to talk
about peloton home exercise bikes this
is really one of my favorite ways to
workout mostly because it's just so
flexible the idea of having an exercise
bike is a great one it's a really good
workout cardiovascular fitness is
important we all know that but the idea
that you can do it whenever you want and
still enjoy the feature
years of a class with an instructor sort
of egging you on so I don't know how
your schedule works I don't know when
I'm gonna have time to work out and so
forth and also my motivation comes and
goes so I like having someone there
telling me what to do it's a virtual
person if you're on peloton so you can
either sign up for a live class or a
large library of pre-taped classes now
peloton has a new 30-day home trial so
you buy the service and try it out worry
free for 30 days if you decide it's not
for you you can return the bike for a
full refund peloton will even come and
pick it up at no cost so this holiday
give the gift to peloton use a promo
code mindscape at 1 peloton calm that's
oh and E peloton PE l OTO and calm and
get $100 off accessories when you
purchase the peloton bike
but okay but so when when when I think
about division of labor and maybe
division of knowledge egos the same way
I think about you know the Industrial
Revolution I think about Henry Ford
building the Model T in an assembly line
and I've too many questions to ask
that's why I'm hesitating here
how did that get started who invented
that was that was that a sort of a side
product of other technological
information innovations like the
printing press or is there a story to
tell about how information spread upon
itself so now we have more of like a big
history question like this yeah so in in
that big history perspective I do think
that there's kind of like a long you
know line of events but they're also
some transitions that I think are very
important you know the first one that
someone like you already like emphasizes
quite a bit on on sapiens is like the
cognitive revolution it's like the
development of language and and there's
some particular properties of language
you know that we have because human
languages are not like animal
communication systems we have the
ability to talk about hypothetical
things you know so al ape can have the
ability to maybe tell another ape that
there's danger or that there's a line
under the snake but they cannot tell
them about their idea for their new
blockbuster film know that idea to talk
about fiction was a big you know
cognitive revolution that happened you
know eighty thousand years ago 100
thousand years ago you know and that is
expressing in in things like the
development of you know like more
advanced tools and and an acceleration
of our ability to you know accumulate
knowledge and and so forth then we have
the Cultural Revolution you know which
people know about that's you know much
more reason about like 10,000 years ago
you know with that we finally start
accumulating slowly people into cities
you know that agglomeration is really
important because at the end of the day
you know just like a biology you know
accumulates knowledge you know in in DNA
and that knowledge has to be preserved
and passed on to the next generation
we humans accumulate cultural knowledge
and and were all dispersed in small
groups the ability to accumulate
knowledge and ideas through generations
you know is limited but once we start
forming cities we start you know living
together we're gonna accumulate more
knowledge we're gonna have maybe also
people that are gonna be dedicated you
know to the
aspects of life in the beginning may be
religious leaders you know and political
leaders and so forth and the next
revolution I would say in the sequence
of events at least the way that I
understand them is the writing
revolution you know and that is very
important in ancient Greece you know
like even though writing is older than
ancient Greeks you know it was not that
prevalent and it was not that advanced
you know it was like much more based on
like you know accounting systems or or
even in in administration and religious
events but in ancient Greece you know
writing kind of like explodes as a form
of expression that is used to
communicate you know and undocumented
ia's and they go through something that
could because you're similar to the
Renaissance you know that happens later
you know they actually get close you
know to maybe you know like what could
have been an industrial revolution maybe
you know if if history would have worked
differently you know and that writing
revolution produces a lot of knowledge
and then after the writing revolution
which I would date you know loosely
around 700 BC to me the next big
revolution and what is the starting
point of everything that is modern is
the printing press you know because when
a Gutenberg you know adapts the printing
press you know that that existed in Asia
and and develops this removable type
printing press what what happens are a
lot of things first you know and this is
all from a list of attention Stein's
work you know the printing presses an
agent of change but first you know for
the first time scientists and scholars
can have access to multiple books like
before printing like only Kings had
little libraries books were transcribed
by hand and everybody has written a book
quickly realizes that no matter how cool
your life is you don't have enough
stories you have to read to and share
other people's stories to fill up your
books you know second you know what
happens also is that printing is the
first economic activity that is urban
and scalable think before printing what
was the way in which you could make
money like that you could make it big
you know well you know you had to have
access to resources where it is a lot of
land a lot of
you know that would like farm that land
you might have access to maybe mineral
resources or you like looted next to
hers town or something like that but
printing was something that you could
produce in a city you know with a
relatively small type of team of people
it was kind of like you know sort of IP
intensive very IP intensive but if you
have a book that's sold and you could
sell copies you could you know become
rich really quickly and evidence of that
is that the number of printers per
capita in Europe stabilized after only
50 years so it was a long 0-60 very
quickly yes yeah it was a huge economic
move like in 50 years
you know you stabilized that number
because you have an activity that
basically was very profitable was very
urban so is the first time that kind of
like someone in the city you know can
really start making it big by
manufacturing something at scale you
know it's really the first type of like
you know mass production is printing you
know and then we was it was content as
we will call it today right yes is that
that was the point you got to monetize
your content for the first time ever
yeah so that I think is huge and you
know it gives rise to like a new
cognitive revolution you know that we we
called enlightenment you know eventually
you know that that involves a lot of the
the most important discoveries of you
know science in the middle of millennia
and and after that you know as a society
chugs along and you know the 6070
century comes along you know printing
accelerates you know like it takes 200
years for people to discover that you
could print short formats okay okay like
magazine some pamphlets and so forth
eventually those lead to a change of
institutions you know so you know it's
hard to understand the transition from
you know monarchies to democracy without
printing and you know after those
changes of institutions you know and
with the acceleration of Science and
Technology we develop new forms of
communication like you know film and
radio then television now the internet
and I like to think of the history of
our planet or of our lasts you know
thousands of years as a history of
changes in communication technologies
that have reconfigured the way that we
create and process information and that
we generate and produce knowledge
and those are the errors that to me have
contributed to this big history yeah now
that's very helpful because I guess we
glossed over a little bit but in your
book you certainly emphasized the fact
that not only there's this thing called
information but it's embodied it's
crystallized
right it's there's some stuff that
carries the information and all these
changes in communication technology
which sounds sort of mundane when you
put it that way they're new information
flow technologies right and it is if you
make it cheaper for information to flow
you enable a lot of new things they're
huge and they're always left upon when
when they first search you know like
nobody took Twitter seriously and
probably now is that the first thing
that politicians take seriously because
like it's still complaining about it but
yeah yeah important it's it's it's quick
like in for instance think of like a the
music industry you know a lot of people
are sort of like surprised that
musicians kind of make money anymore
but if you think about it from the
perspective of communication
technologies what it's curious is that
there was a short period of time in
which they could make money yeah because
there were musicians at the time of the
ancient Greek they're musicians is still
today but for most history musicians
only could perform live and you know
live performance were hard to monetize
they couldn't spread but as you know
technology evolved and you had radio and
then more than radio you had then
records you know those records you know
allowed to constrain the diffusion of
music in such a way that you could
monetize it because music was trapped on
those you know discs it was trapped you
know on those magnetic tapes and you
could make killing because you know the
marginal cost of producing a new tape or
disk was very small you know you could
sell them for 10 $15 you know and all of
the musicians that that were big in the
60s 70s and 80s they are loaded you know
nowadays you know it's impossible to
make money that way because music cannot
be trapped in a physical media and and
what was curious is that musicians could
make money for a while so the it that's
that's interesting when you put it it
had to be shareable but not too
shareable exactly yeah there's that
sweet spot in it I wonder what lessons
there are for other things I wonder if
your books are the same way I mean
certainly as someone who writes books
you probably feel the same way
the first thing that happens when you
write a book is pirated versions appear
on the internet but they're not that
better than the physical book so I don't
think it's doing a huge amount of damage
that's interesting okay so that that
flow of information through different
media obviously affects what people can
do but then how where do we get to
things like Henry Ford and you have this
wonderful example in the book of this
giant plant I've never heard of it
before but there was you know what was
it called the River Rouge River Rouge
yeah I didn't know about this before but
to this day that was the largest you
know integrated facility I don't know
because I've been to China loathe and
like okay like they have amazing I
didn't grow monotonically there was a
peak at that not exactly so the River
Rouge you know was this you know
fantastic plant you know that that that
Ford created that that literally like
took like soybeans and metal you know on
one end and produce cars out of the
other because it was a complete vertical
integration yeah I would say today we
don't manufacture anything with that
level of vertical integration like value
chains are very distributed and
international you know that's for
instance why like tram cars are kind of
like stupid when it involves Mexico
because you know the u.s. value chain in
the automotive sector like you know
which is the number one country in the
exports of beer it's also Mexico because
you know a lot of like the u.s. beers
manufacture so like the value chains are
integrated and disaggregated between
different countries you know and we
don't have those monolithic models but
at the time you know of a Henry Ford you
know where like transportation was not
that good that's why you know those
those those slow cars were such a good
business you know a you you needed maybe
to produce that level of vertical
integration to be able to get the
economies of scale that he needed you
know to produce four level vehicles you
know and nowadays things are different
but it's impressive you know what they
were able to go at some point and we
again maybe it's a version of a sweet
spot in that they had the
differentiation of knowledge enough to
do the economy of scale but it was still
expensive to do things all over the
place
so bringing it together in the same
geographic location was a useful thing
but I think in the book you have this
example I'm gonna mangle it but you know
in Chile you can mine copper and
the raw materials and you would like to
have a battery and you can in principle
make them but it's actually cheapest to
just send your raw materials to Korea
have them make the batteries and then
buy it back yes so that's a good point
because at the end of the day you know
like for us to produce things you need
to combine you know like you know
materials technology and knowledge you
know and the way that the world works is
that the world is kind of like Lacey
yeah like we like basically try to
minimize costs that's that's a more
economical way of putting it but because
of that you have to ask yourself the
question what is easier to move is it
easier to move the knowledge is it
easier to move the materials is easy to
move the technology what are the factors
are easy to move on and the hardest
factor to move is knowledge you know so
there seems weird
I mean knowledge is not very heavy but
it's it's hard to move it from brain to
brain I suppose it's super heavy because
and people tend to confuse knowledge
with kind of like encoded pieces of
information you know so like would you
trust a brain surgeon that the only
thing that has done is read Wikipedia
pages about brain surgery and has never
been there so like knowledge is very
experiential or even read a textbook
exactly yeah yeah someone that had just
read a textbook on on brain surgery I
wouldn't allow them to operate you know
and they don't you know like that's why
you have residency's and you have all of
this you know practice systems you know
but when it comes to like complex
industries you know the knowledge is
embedded on on large teams and that
makes it very hard to move so knowledge
has these temporary monopolies so for
example when Ford figures out how to
build a car and he's able to put all of
that together on the River Rouge and
he's producing cars and they're silent
people producing cars also not that far
from him they're not producing cars in
San Diego they're producing cars you
know like they're in the Midwest right
yeah exactly on Detroit you know and and
it spans kind of like from there because
knowledge is hard to move so it's easier
to bring the steel there it's breathing
to be you know the coal and all of the
other materials and nowadays I think
it's kind of like the same you know like
like Silicon Valley has monopolies over
markets that they discover China is now
getting there because the country that
is very technologically advanced and
sophisticated and the products are
easier to move that the knowledge that
you need to make them so if you figure
out something
you know that people want you're gonna
have that monopoly because the product
is gonna diffuse very quickly you know
but the ability to make it is gonna
diffuse very slowly and until it does
you know there's gonna be only a few
people that are gonna be able to supply
that and therefore you know they're
gonna have their day and this is related
to that distinction you draw between
knowledge and know-how or explicit
knowledge I guess and know-how I mean in
some sense there are things you can put
in a book but there are things that are
just in the human brain or just in the
individual people and that's why it's
heavy because moving people is really
hard exactly so in the in the literature
on knowledge that is used traditionally
on business schools and knowledge
economics innovation economics people
make a strong distinction between tacit
and explicit knowledge explicit
knowledge is all of the knowledge that I
can communicate through an act of
communication I can qualify that
knowledge like the recipe that I can put
on a cookbook is something you know that
I could communicate through a page and
therefore is explicit knowledge the
experience of having cooked with you
know the chefs from El Bulli or any
famous restaurant is something you know
that is much harder to communicate so it
would because your tacit knowledge so
the best examples of tacit knowledge are
think of sports so imagine like Michael
Jordan he's extremely talented he really
knows how to handle a ball on you know a
basketball court
but imagine you have a seminar and he
speaks and tells you about basketball
for like three days you know how much
better of a player you're gonna be after
the third day and so on yeah yeah not
much you know because you know that
knowledge is fasted and its acquired
through practice and the world is full
of tacit knowledge and is the one that
is hardest to see because it's not as
obvious as the knowledge that we can
codify and closer to our experience I
don't know if you have a professional
basketball in your career in your past
but graduate school is the same way
right you know students come in they
know a lot of equations or whatever but
they don't know what it means to be a
scientist they haven't seen it in action
they haven't done it I agree yeah so I
came to the US for grad school and I I
had a very good advice or you know last
oh but Abbas is a very famous you know
physicist that works on networks and and
so forth and a I remembered like soon I
learned that I
it was a waste of time to go to him to
like kind of like talk to him about like
technical details sorry that that you
should figure out by yourself but but
what I wanted to get out of him is like
to understand okay when a problem is
relevant you know how should I
communicate to people you know how is
different people gonna interpret this
all of those type of things you know
how to think about you know like a
career and to connect the different
things that you are doing and those are
things that are hard to learn if you
don't have a model of someone that you
know knows how to do them and you're
kind of like learning as an apprentice
and and I think a lot of people
sometimes don't understand that I think
the 20s you know you better get someone
you know that that is where you want to
be and and we have very humble
apprentice of them so if we if we take
this on board and we appreciate the
importance of tacit knowledge and
know-how and and how difficult it is to
move around what are the lessons that we
get from that for either building an
organization or organizing economy or
trade barriers and things like that so
there's a lot of lessons because there's
a big literature on this you know and so
there's the literature that looks at the
geographic diffusion of knowledge you
know and as you can imagine because
knowledge is sticky there's a lot of
barriers to the diffusion so it's hard
for knowledge to travel long distances
now the reason why it's hard for
knowledge to travel long distances is
because it's socially embedded so like
it's actually that social networks are
geographically circumscribed and that
limits the diffusion of knowledge so
then the question is what are the things
that limit the ability of people to
create links you know you have language
barriers you have cultural barriers all
of those have been shown extensively to
limit knowledge diffusion to limit trade
to meet other things No so the question
then is like now if you're a country or
a city or a region that wants to develop
their economy you know what are you
trying to do is to accumulate knowledge
and the question is how do you do it by
following the loss of knowledge
diffusion okay and here they're examples
of people that did it wrong and examples
of people that did things better know
examples of doing it wrong I don't have
you ever heard of the University of
Judge shy in Ecuador no so earlier this
decade a Rafael Correa
who was the president of Ecuador I
decided to put a billion dollars you
know on the creation of a new city of
science and technology that he hoped
would compete with knowledge production
centers across the world very idealistic
you know plan you know a billion dollars
in Ecuador
it's 1% of GDP ok so that's that's a lot
of cake you know and basically you know
what they did is they grabbed a piece of
agricultural land like two hours north
of Quito and they try to start building
kind of like this university and city
and industrial park and so forth but you
if you walk around you know place like
Kendall Square of Manhattan you know
that you don't build a lot for a billion
dollars you know and if you have to
bring every break and every person that
lay breaks to the place you build even
less so quickly like the plan you know
like unravel you know that university
has gone through like six or seven you
know a university presidents by now they
were able to tracked a few scientists to
move there you know that didn't go well
you know there was an article in science
you know talking about the experience
and how they some of them were leaving
some of them got fired they got a few
students there like like like at the
beginning like I think it was just a
thousand you know that became very
radicalized because they believed on the
dream but you know a thousand dollars
you know sorry a thousands two inside a
billion dollars no that's a million
dollars per student so you could have
put all of these kids in Stanford you
know for like life you know and you know
so so they were like you know and I'm
basically was this idea that if you have
enough money you could create knowledge
anywhere yeah and that's not true
because their process of diffusion that
constrained the creation of knowledge in
the case of Ecuador they had two chances
one was called well you killed that one
was called Quito you know which are the
like two centers you know where they
have accumulated knowledge and so what
are the channels that can promote
knowledge diffusion so one of them which
is really important and it's also very
well documented is migration a and
migration is one channel that is also
very biased towards the most talented
people in the world so there's a book by
Bill Kerr which is a professor at HBS
that is called the gift of global
and in that book you know you find a lot
of interesting facts one of them is like
people you know without a college degree
about 1% of them migrate people with a
college degree is about like 5%
inventors that have filed a patent about
10% Nobel Prize winners about 31% Nobel
Prize winners in the US since the 70s
it's like 60 something promotional
everywhere
exactly no so you do have kind of like
this thing that there is a tale of
talent that is extremely global and that
is the one that helps create innovation
the ones that help create jobs you know
is similar you get similar numbers if
you focus not only on formal education
and academic credentials if you look at
people that have form you know fortune
500 companies or unicorns they're super
biased towards forints you know so then
you know one of the lessons that you
need to do is you know well how do you
attract that global talent you know
because at the end of the day it's a
game of global talent because also these
talented famous individuals are the ones
that are gonna help you attract other
ones the u.s. for a long time has had a
huge advantage in that space it receives
about 50 percent of all of the PhD star
migrating the world can only to one
destination which is the u.s. you know
and now that following percentage I
presume now may change yeah yeah well I
I that's a very believable story I had
two previous podcasts which made similar
points one with Jeffrey West about
health in scale and you know the
ingenuity and creativity certainly
scales with population density in some
way and then another one with will
Wilkinson where we talked about the
political aspects of these and the
openness to new ideas that was
associated with cities versus a more
conservative rural divide but then so
that raises the question that you
brought up the word inequality earlier
you know it's great to attract the best
talent and you know they want to be in
these concentrations of brilliance and
productivity but then how do you spread
the rewards of all that productivity and
brilliance widely to everyone so that
stuff but I do think that
we have found out a few things you know
quite recently actually so um
without going into the details we might
go into this later but there are ways of
measuring you know the knowledge
intensity of economies you know like how
much knowledge is there in New York
vis-a-vis San Diego Tokyo Moscow
whatever you know and when you use those
measures to look at knowledge
concentration in cities or in countries
you do find relationships with
inequality as well so for instance
economies that are more complex tend to
be less unequal economies that are more
attractive and less complex sorry
economies that are more complex are less
unequal more equal more equal exactly
and economies that are less complex are
more unequal okay you know so it's not
obvious to me it's not obvious but like
it's really hard to have the level of
inequality of Switzerland with the
industrial structure of Peru you know so
if your exports are based on like three
four sectors mainly you know when those
sectors are about you know mineral
resources traction that you know are
industries that are very regimented and
hierarchical you know because they're
about like you know safety about
production that they're not about
creativity you don't want a miner to
start digging anywhere exactly so you
have a practice structures that are not
geared towards you know innovation and
then you know a gears like towards
structures are more hierarchical and and
unequal so at the international scale
you know as economies become more
complex they become more equal and a
second amis become less complex they
become more unequal so for countries
like you know like Chile and you know
Peru and Angola all of these countries
that depend a lot on Mineral Resources
traction whether these are fossil fuels
or other forms of minerals one thing
that they need to do to reduce that
inequality is they need to sophisticate
the practice structure so they can
generate those middle-income jobs
because those my own income jobs are not
gonna happen
you know just through the redistributed
policies you do need policies and social
safety nets but you do need to change
the practice structure now if you look
inside countries the relationship flips
which is kind of cool you know from Ana
statistical perspective
why that might be our hypothesis right
now is that because within countries you
do have more spatial equilibrium okay so
a lot of the effects that Geoffrey West
talks about you know are effects that
are not just about the size of cities
but also about the migration into cities
so repeater Hedstrom has a paper on
science advances that finds that all
those super-lean and scale in
relationships described by western Baron
could are actually quite explained by
migrants coming to cities and those
migrants being the most talented people
so the most talented people from the
rural areas are the ones on migrate and
help provide that extra punch of
productivity that cities have so a city
like New York is very unequal not
because it's only based on New Yorkers
it's because a lot of like poor people
migrate to those places similar to San
Francisco you know they're like big
magnets and attractors of people and at
the country scale the more complex
regional cities the more inequalities
the least complex the more equality so
you have a Simpsons paradox you know not
from Homer Simpson yeah but the
statistical seem some paragraphs that
the correlation that you serve at one
scale I know inverse when you
disaggregate the data into the next
scale right okay well so the multi is
there an immediate policy implication
for this so what we're going to do it
it's knowledge yeah so I do think that
there are few things one thing that we
found also related to this is that in
the more complex economic activities
concentrating space much more than the
least complex economic activities that
paper is coming out of nature human
behavior in a few weeks and what this
tells us is that well if at the end of
the day wealth is gonna be increasingly
be generated in cities we do need to
have you know better ways of including
more people into cities because I think
one of the pain points of the United
States right now is that the major
cities of the US are failing to
accommodate more people because of
problems is infrastructure no problems
in the ability to build and so forth so
like if you think about it like San
Francisco based on the worst obvious
problem that city in China would be a 20
million people city given you know like
what is able to make but for that you
know it would have you know 27 lines of
subway okay that would be like really
fast and modern an autonomous you know
it
it would need to have another type of
infrastructure like I don't have you
been to Shenzhen I've not been there but
I know about it yeah came into existence
from nothing yeah 23 million people like
so so the US haven't hasn't been able to
produce 21st century mega cities it
produced 20 century mega cities but
nowadays you know I think you're gonna
need to include more people in the
centers of production and if you don't
get together you know good
infrastructure for transportation you
don't get to get good ways of like
densifying neighborhoods you know in a
way that they make them livable but at
the same time are able to include maybe
twice the number of people that they had
before maybe three times no you're gonna
start having more and more social
pressure because it's unsustainable to
commute for three hours you know like
people are getting excluded because
cities you know have the need to include
more people than the one that they're
able to right now I mean just to play
devil's advocate here I'm probably
mostly on your side but these are subtle
questions where we're having this
conversation in the middle of a charming
neighborhood of Cambridge Massachusetts
with a lot of small individual sized
houses or at least few unit houses the
character of the place would utterly
change if the density were that of a
large Chinese megalopolis right and is
that entirely good well you know in in
some ways I live two blocks away from
here yeah that's a huge privilege yeah
you know that's a huge privilege and
we're gonna give it up yeah many people
in my company have to commute much
longer and that commute is is part of
kind of like their unhappiness and if
you think about it a lot of the social
unrest that is happening in many
countries you know is happening you know
it's being triggered when the price of
gas goes up when the price of
transportation goes up because commuters
are unhappy you know commuters are the
ones that are kind of like excluded and
they have to kind of like make a journey
every day to the places where people
like me that have the privilege to be
able to afford a home here you know live
so I do think that if they could make
Cambridge more you know affordable to
more people hmm
you know I think it probably would be
healthier you know maybe we'll be able
to hang out at night more and get better
ideas for our businesses and for
creative activities our
so I I do think that if you get along
with your neighbors it's good to have
more of them it is I was impressed to
learn not impressed but interested to
learn that the average commute time goes
up and up the more you're in a big city
yes despite the fact that things are
more dense and nearby it takes longer to
get there yes la so we have all of that
data you know we have data USA we have
the main tool to distribute and
visualize US public data that we
launched in 2016 and there you can
create maps of like commute times and
you immediately see that when you create
the average travel time map boom
all of the cities light up when you
create the commuting alone map then you
know it's the opposite and also
commuting alone you know it's people
driving cars in more rural areas you
know average travel time you know goes
up you know in places like DC and and
you know New York and so forth well
that's another side of what you do so if
information flowing around in different
forms and in different media is driving
the economy in various ways we're living
in an era now where there's so much
information that just dealing with it
all is a big issue so you've been
involved in data visualization and
projects that try to sort of make sense
of all this information we're getting
what drives you to do that so it was a
little bit of a let's say you know lucky
path you know so when I started doing
this work on economic complexity and
relatedness there were like two big
papers that we produce one in 2007 that
came out in science and another one in
PNAS in 2009 and those papers became you
know very popular but one of the things
that those papers had was that they had
some non-traditional techniques that we
had invented that you could use to
predict the products that a country was
gonna export in the future know that you
could use to predict the future economic
growth potential you know of countries
based on their economic structures and I
started to get a lot of demand you know
of people to generate you know reports
on that type of topic you know and and
as a scientist you know like you always
want to be working on the next thing you
know so like they say Oriya we want to
do
you know like relatedness and complexity
analysis for this region of Brazil or
for you know these are that and and that
was kind of like boring repetitive work
because he done better yeah you've done
it so when I started my my lab at MIT
the first grad student that I hired was
Alex
Seymour's and the the job that I gave
him is we're gonna do like a
self-service tool for this demand I had
done something similar before for a
paper in which we look at you know
correlations between diseases using
hospitalization records and Alex started
building you know this tool which became
the cell battery of economic complexity
is now the number one tool to distribute
international trade date in the world
you know and then we found out that you
know maybe like what people were more
interested was on the platform on the
tool rather than you know the analysis
that the tool made and that was really
plausible so then we created a tool you
know together with the government of
miniaturizing Brazil that you know
integrated data for more than 50 million
workers although they basically form our
sector economy Brazil they don't trade
on industries you know and a employment
and also education for all Brazil and
then you know together with a colleague
from Deloitte we started working on the
creation of a similar platform for the
US but one of the things that we did
there is that we realized that you know
we needed to go beyond the economic data
you know so it include data on
demographics on health on insurance on
you know commute times on you name it
done and that's data you say that was
launched in 2016
that pretty became very popular and and
it became some sort of like the the
dream thing that people in statistics
departments of many governments in the
world wanted to have and that started to
generate a demand or to create more
projects like that so you know there's
data Korea now there is data Chile we're
releasing data Mexico on January and
we've been creating these tools that
what they do is something that is very
simple but it's not easy to do you know
it's easy to use but it's hard to do is
to integrate you know 15 20 30 different
datasets but not just provide files but
integrate them into narratives so what
we do is we transform data into stories
you know that's the main form of
integration that we provide that allows
people to
find the date on the web know the
stories have you know text that is
generated semi algorithmically using the
data visualizations also you know so
imagine for the US the US has like
70,000 census-designated places you know
each one of them has you know a complete
profile you know with more than 70
visualizations and a lot of text and
information so even if you're a little
town you have all of your census data
and your be a data and your BLS dating
date that you say and then we have more
advanced tools like ways to integrate
data and download it you know but
integrating data from multiple sources
ways of creating custom visualizations
and that has been you know something
that that has done you know very well
also we've done similar solution for
private sector companies in which we
integrate the data from their marketing
departments and logistics and so forth
to create platforms that people can use
in a strategic decision-making and are
these also useful for academics doing
studies yeah demography or whatever they
use it also like just to give an idea
right now on our online properties we
get over a million people a month okay
so we run service you know to try to
figure out you know who they are and how
we can serve them better and like a
platform like data us a you know a
thirty five to forty percent of the
people that that visited it's like
academic of some form whether it is like
a high school student doing a homework
yeah what it is a university professor
you know using it in some report like if
you if you go to Google Scholar and you
search for the URL it would be a
relatively well cited paper like
unfortunately you don't get maybe one
day you know you're gonna be able to put
your websites on Google Scholar as well
but that's another story and so we do
get people from academia we do get a lot
of people from local governments okay
and people just go to the website and
use it is it no it's totally free right
now we're thinking maybe in the future
to add some premium features you know
for like you know people that are using
this some people use it for example to
do market analysis you know and we could
provide like freemium features in that
case but so far is completely free
open-source you know so it's a very open
project and is that similar to you also
mentioned offhandedly the urban
perception the idea of using
actual photographs of different places
in the city - sort of but but not just
show them in a slideshow but learn about
them yeah it's related because if you
see what I'm interested in I'm
interested on kind of like these
applications of science and technology
to society you know and one of the
things that I tried to do over the last
decade is to find alternative ways to
collect data and hopefully data about
aspects of society had been hard to
quantify before so in 2010 and I got the
idea that we could use Google Street
view images to quantify evaluative
aspects of cities you know which place
looks safe which place look lively which
place you know look depressing beautiful
and so forth at that time a lot of
people were like oh this is crazy these
are all subjective things and never
gonna be able to do it is all
meaningless but I discovered that on the
one hand there was a literature and
urban planning of people that have
attempted and had done that many times
but with very very small sample sizes
above both images and you know people so
what I did is I did a crowdsourcing
study and that quickly became the
largest data set ever you know of visual
perception service that was called place
pools and that allows us to classify
4000 images and we got over 100,000
people rating them and we discovered a
few things first that people's
preferences were very transitive so okay
yeah so it's not that you know that all
over the place like if I show you like a
picture of a really nice you know like
beautiful well camped neighborhood and I
show you like a picture over you know
like a very you know sketchy you know
favela or industrial you know like
people tend to let's say answer that the
first one is safer than the second one
and that tends to be quite a universal
preference so so the difference between
images is so large that it overwhelms
the differences between people mmm and
we could use those those scores to like
measure you know like aggregation you
don't know if it's actually safe oh you
know everyone perceives it to be safe
yeah and we don't expect it to be
because I wanted to measure was the
perception because perception can also
have an effect that is independent of
whether that location is actually safe
or not so they're different things they
don't have to be the same actually we've
all been in cities in neighborhoods
where years said oh this looks safe or
oh this doesn't look safe and you know
with articulating what we're saying that
I'd be difficult exactly so what we
discovered though is that crowdsourcing
was very limited for them amount of data
that we needed to collect so a city like
New York Manhattan alone has about
80,000 street segments so a lot of a
straight segment so let's say you want
to get one image per street segment you
know and you want to evaluate that image
and let's say that you you you want to
compare very much with only ten others
you know to be able to get a decent
score you know it's it's imagine it's
like college football but with you know
like eighty thousand teams and for every
games
know exactly you know so it's super
under determined matrix you know still
you need a lot of traffic just to
evaluate all of those images for one
city in one dimension so what we decided
to do is to say let's grab the data that
we have and let's train computer vision
algorithms to like do the clicking for
us okay and we find that actually those
computer algorithms work very well and
allowed us to scale to create you know
urban perception maps with hundreds of
thousands of images and then we could
use that to study how perception
affected behavior okay and what would we
find so we teamed up with a team of
Italian colleagues that had mobile phone
data and they could see the activity of
people in cities as a function of the
time of the day you know so then we
could see if people tended to avoid and
save look in places you know a
controlling for distance to the subway
for this as to the central business
district for other things like the a
density of jobs the density of
population and so forth and we did find
very interesting effects so we first we
find that like people tend to avoid and
save looking places right after
controlling for all those things you
find less people in those places then
you would expect and those effects are
modulated by
more graphics so it's stronger for women
and for the elderly but it's reversed
for you know people below 30
so like young people tend to like they
hang out hang out save looking places
you know young male especially you know
but like elderly women can to avoid
those places and it kind of like makes
sense but it helps formalize something
that I think will have an intuition for
but now you know we actually have like
you know hardcore data to be able to
show it I mean it's another example of
what we were talking about a different
way of thinking about conceptualizing
different kind of information in some
sense or at least a different way of of
sharing it and thinking about it and
that's the other last thing I wanted to
ask you about was how this relates to
your interest in collective memory I did
have one podcast guest Lynne Kelly who
studies memory palaces ancient memory
palaces so the idea of remembering
things by associating them with you know
physical geographical location she
thinks that Stonehenge for example was
used as a way of remembering what you
had called know-how right tacit
knowledge that was because they didn't
have writing they couldn't pass it down
that easily but nowadays we have the
internet we have books we have TV it's a
very different kind of thing how is our
collective memory of who we are and what
kinds of things we pay attention to been
affected by these technological changes
yes so I study how collective memory is
affected by by technology language and
time so we need a paper you know with
stinker and other people in which we
looked at the network of global
languages ok so that's a network in
which each node is a language a language
are connected if they're likely to be
translated or spoken by the same people
so let's say English might be connected
to German if a lot of books get
translated from one language to another
and a lot of people that speak German
also speak English and so forth and we
map that Network using three data sets a
data set with over two million book
translations Twitter so we detected the
language you know of tweets and then if
you tweet in English and you tweet in
Spanish you know I can connect those two
languages because you are expressing
knowledge both and Wikipedia edits you
know so it's not reading Wikipedia but
if you edited the page you know of
Einstein in German and you need to
the page of Einstein in English you
probably know how to ride in German so
you probably know both languages and
interestingly enough when we compare
that Network you know with data set that
we created of globally famous people we
found that the centrality of a language
in that network explained the number of
famous people produced by the language
better than the population of the
language better than the wealth of that
language you know so that tells us a you
know like Fame you know or global fame
is something that is very much dependent
on on like this network because if you
think about it the network of languages
is like the most aggregate version of
the global social network that you can
have you cannot have a social
relationship if you don't speak a
language you know you kind of make a
friend just by nodding you know so in
that context you know we learned that
you know much of what the world knows is
gonna be modulated by this network and
then and there's a lot of implications
about that you know so just to be clear
this is the network take the form of
saying things like if you know English
you're more likely to know French than
Chinese whereas if you know Chinese
you're more likely to know Korean than
to know English things like that exactly
so the network gathers all those names
it's it's you know their paths between
every language and every language but a
language like English for instance is a
global hub you know so someone from
Portugal and someone from Vietnam
probably is gonna speak something the
most likely things they're gonna speak
English yeah that's a bad example but
there's also like regional hubs you know
so like for example French connects a
lot with African languages you know a
also you know a Spanish connects with
like you know Quechua and you know a map
with moon and other you know languages
from you know say native South America
you know then you have also Arabic has
been an original have Chinese you know
and then you have languages like Russian
is a very important regional have on all
you know like Eastern Europe and in
North East Asia you know and then you
have peripheral languages so it's a very
hierarchical network with like English
Sigma in the centre then a ring of you
know regional hubs and then you know
like smaller languages that are kind of
like on the periphery you know connected
to some of those regional hubs
and I would love to see a picture of
this is there any language very good
thing and then we also studied how
communication technologies affected our
collective memory and we use this data
set that we've created of over 70,000
famous biographies to look at how
changes in technology change the number
of globally famous people that were born
each year and the occupations associated
to those people so for instance you know
when you think of you know I shine he
would be a physicist when I think of
Michelangelo he would be you know a
painter no and what you find is that
when new communication technologies were
introduced the composition of our
collective memory changed not only the
size so before printing you look at the
matrix of our collective memory it is
mostly political and religious leaders
okay after printing bosses of
hierarchies one way or the other
exactly you know after printing you get
famous artists and famous scientists for
the first time you get a lot of painters
you get composers you know you start
getting astronomers no writers you know
that they're also there but then there
is the second printing error which we
talked before when people start doing
like shortage formats and so forth and
there you have an explosion on the
sciences then now you start
differentiating you know natural
philosophy into more sciences you know
you get a lot of famous writers and so
forth and composers you know and then
you have the invention of film and radio
and that generates a huge shift on the
arts because before that it was the
painter and the composer then it's about
the performer so is the musician is the
singer composers disappear musicians and
singers are the ones that now become
famous actors become famous not play
writers anymore you know so there's kind
of like that shift and then you have the
introduction of television with
television you create the fame of
sportsmen no because sportsmen we're not
that I'm a performer yeah before
television and and it's a live
performance you know like it has to be
at the right time when you watch the
game and and visible in 3d and yeah
exactly you can experience it there yeah
okay so so you do have kind of like that
change in the composition of our
collective memory with introduction of
negation technologies and and it's it's
very clear so to me when now when I
think about like the history I don't
think about like the modern times and
the Renaissance and the things that I
learned in school I think of it in terms
of like okay what was the dominant
communication technology at the time and
that's the era that I understood myself
in and what's gonna come next
yeah so the next thing that I use
Instagram influencers next time that I
like well what what is I do you know
tick tock I know of it I've never used
it yet oh dude or far behind it's you
don't need an account to watch okay that
already tells you something so you know
it's it's massive I think in different
ways first it's like the quality of the
performance that you've served there
it's very good you know the amount of
attention also that is some tick tock is
it's amazing like there's you know like
all of these videos getting like
millions and millions and millions of
likes so it's not you know like a
marginal traffic it's it's huge
you know and it's the first global
social media because it's a Chinese
company so it's the only social media
that is popular in both China and the
West you know which makes it quite
interesting as a as a as a global
phenomenon you know and it's not based
on pure communication it's it's actually
broadcasting so you know ok indictable
you have like two channels they for you
which is like a TV feed in which you
just scroll and the following which is
the people that you're following you
have a feed of who you follow and that's
it you know you can search the search is
horrible and that's a work that doesn't
provide good results and and it's very
passive like television so they
reinvented television for the phone era
you know in a zapping world in which
like content is 15 30 seconds long and
you know you know it is those 15 30
seconds there's a lot of good quality
content at that range of size I mean
Twitter and podcasters cutting edges are
gonna get I think technologically but
yeah they they keep coming along very
quickly so yeah and so I guess the the
point is that how we think about
ourselves changes when these media
change right how we remember ourselves
indeed what I want to say about it
though that I like which is interesting
I do think that is more social and more
family so when I use Twitter you
by myself when I use Facebook is by
Michelle when I watch tick-tock I'm in
the couch with my wife and my daughter
and the three of us are looking at the
same screen at the same time I'm talking
about what we're watching and I do think
that that's important because we do have
a lot of interactions right now in which
people are interacting with screens
independently yeah and I grew up
probably you grew up you know with
people sitting in front of a television
and and and having that more of as a
collective experience you know in which
you have to negotiate what you watch you
have to talk about what you watch and
and and I do find that you know that's
that's a good thing compared to like the
social media there has been more peer to
peer but isolating well I'd like to end
on optimistic notes is that your
optimistic note and what do you think
about the future what should our
optimism be where should be located I
I'm an optimist you know and I I don't
know that's a good thing or a bad thing
and I think maybe genetics but I tend to
be optimistic even though you know like
today you know Chile is going through a
very difficult moment with all of the
the things that have happened they are
doing the last four or five days but I
do think that at the end of the day you
know in the positive things in life tend
to add up you know and build on each
other better than the negative things in
life so going back to the beginning we
talked about where information or the
growth and that's because our ability to
create order and complexity it's larger
than the radar which is getting
destroyed and I think that's also true
for many of the positive things you know
so I am an optimist because I do think
that at the end of the day you know
things add up you know better you know
us as we move along all right Stacy
Hidalgo thanks for some good information
there thanks for being on the podcast
hey my pleasure
[Music]
you